okay we're going to get started with
today's NCBI minute thank you for coming
today let me just put in a plug for our
YouTube channel do you subscribe to our
channel you can get updates of all the
videos we put up on YouTube including
other tutorials in terms of the format
of this webinar our speaker today Kim
Pruett is going to be showing you some
slides about updates to prokaryotic
genome annotation if you have questions
during that go ahead and put those into
the question pod some of those could be
answered while Kim is talking with
others we may answer when she's finished
with the slides
Kim will answer those and others yet we
will put in a document on the courses
and webinars page at NCBI under
materials where you can see a lot more
or less of the questions and answered
these slides today are already up on
this materials link at the bottom of the
slide you're seeing right now that goes
to the NCBI FTP site so without further
ado I'll introduce Kim Pruitt to talk
about updates to prokaryotic genome
annotation okay thank you everybody
I'm Kim Pruitt and I'm the person who's
in charge of refseq eukaryotes and
prokaryotes and if you're not familiar
with refseq in a nutshell it is an NCBI
project to provide reference sequence
standards that incorporate current
knowledge for genomes transcripts and
proteins it's a very large data set but
today I'm going to talk to you about
some of the new features in our
prokaryotic genomes so just to get
started I want I want to give you a
sense of how we create our genomic
records these are made basically from
the submitted data that's coming in to
GenBank or our partner databases in the
insdc which is the international
nucleotide sequence database consortium
our collaboration so you as the
submitter community do a lot of work to
generate genome sequence data to
annotate to assemble that into the
genome sequence that is submitted to
NCBI in some cases you're annotating
that data yourselves where you're taking
advantage of NCBI genome annotation
service for prokaryotic genome
all of that information gets submitted
to GenBank and it's available in our
nucleotide and protein resources
sometimes the raw data is available in
SRA
the information about the assembly
itself is available in ncbi's assembly
resource and metadata about the sample
that was used and about the specific
research project are available also in
our metadata databases the sequence data
and the assembly information is then
copied into the refseq project where we
are then carrying out a whole genome
annotation process this is something
that has changed recently in the
prokaryotic world we used to propagate
annotation from the submitted GenBank
entry and only annotate those that did
not have any annotation but now we are
annotating all prokaryotic genomes using
our annotation pipeline this offers us a
lot of improvement in terms of
consistency of the annotation and in
terms of being able to update them in a
more timely fashion because some
submissions come in and they're never
updated further to reflect new
information and so in our pipeline we
can do this kind of updates so I'm not
going to go into the details about our
pipeline on the previous slide I'm sorry
I moved away from too quickly there was
a link to find more documentation about
the pipeline process flow itself so our
management of the proteins that we
annotate on prokaryotic records has
changed significantly in the past couple
of years the original model that we were
using was that for any given assembled
genome and so the asam the accession
prefix is on the top are two of the
accession prefixes that we use for
genomic sequence records for any given
genome we used to provide a distinct
accession number which I'm showing here
with a wipey accession prefix for each
annotated coding region on that genomic
sequence so the little pinkish boxes are
coding regions and the individual
accessions would be applied per genome
so if you had two isolates of E coli
from to pay
in a hospital we would be providing
separate accession numbers for both of
those so there was no way to correlate
easily that the sequences were actually
identical at the protein level and we
were having a huge increase in
redundancy in the refseq data set and so
we undertook a massive shift in our data
model to address the redundancy issue we
went through an intermediate stage where
we had our original accession numbers
cross linking to our new truly non
redundant refseq protein data set and
these currently help an accession number
prefix that begins with a W key so if
you see an accession WP followed by
underscore you know you're looking at a
truly non redundant refseq protein
record our current model which is the
completion of our transition in our
protein management is that all of our
bacterial and your archaeal records are
directly annotated with the
non-redundant protein record so what
this means is for a given CD s let's say
the first one on my on my picture here
if this protein is identically found in
five other genomes from the same or
different species then we annotate all
six of those genomes with the exact same
accession number so you'll there will be
six genomes that are providing cross
references to this identical protein
sequence so we've significantly reduced
the redundancy in our protein data set
you can see some of the actual measures
of that redundancy in our documentation
page the link is shown at the bottom of
this page where you just plug in the
ncbi root URL here so this offers us an
advantage in terms of redundancy
management but it also has had a very
positive secondary benefit and giving us
a really good way to manage protein
names we can now manage protein names
directly on this level of non-redundant
protein records
without having to Rihanna Tate the
genome we can update the protein record
to offer an improved protein name and
that improved protein name is
automatically propagated to the genomes
that that protein that's annotated on
this is a really strong advantage to
this data model along the way we've also
added some categorizations to refseq
prokaryotes
so we now categorize them as reference
genomes we have a small number of
reference genomes these are the highest
quality complete genomes that are
supported by curation either at ncbi by
NCBI staff scientists or through
communities that we collaborate with so
there's greater confidence in the
sequence of these genomes and in the
annotation on these genomes and I'm just
giving you an example here in my
examples in all three cases here the
first identifier is two ncbi's assembly
database where you can get metadata
about the quality of the assembly the
second identifier is the refseq genome
accession number and then followed by
the species name we also have a category
called representative genomes and what
we're trying to do is select a
representative per species most of these
representatives are high-quality
complete genomes but some of these are
draft and and what we're trying to do is
select the best genome available at this
point in time these are subject to
change over time as we get more genome
sequencing data and for lack of a better
word we're currently calling the
remainder our variant genomes the
majority of these represent bacterial
species from which there have been
thousands and thousands of sequences
submitted for the same organism so we
may have thousands of e coli genome
submissions thousands of Salmonella
genome submissions and these are really
defining variants of this species you
can find information about these
categories reference or representative
by searching our in sembly resource and
here's an example query to find refseq
reference genomes
so this is a picture a screenshot of one
of our non-redundant protein records and
you can see it has the WP accession
number showing up here on the record I
want to point out that these records are
annotated at the lowest common
denominator in terms of what organism
information they carry so if there is a
in this case this is an extreme case
this is something that is annotated on
genomes of different species where the
lowest common denominator of those
species is bacteria and so that is the
organism information that is carried on
this sequence record you might find
others that are carrying organism
information at the level of the genus
and of course there are still many that
carry organism information at the level
of the species there's more information
about the non-redundant protein
sequences available online and at the
top of the page is the URL to that
documentation at the bottom of the page
is the URL to the specific protein
record that I'm showing you here very
recently we've added a database that is
being used to manage protein names and
so within that database we have stored
all of the protein names that are
currently used for our non-redundant
protein records we have stored all of
these Swiss protein names we are
collecting and generating a large
dataset of hmm
we are doing protein clustering we are
looking at identical proteins and we are
curating names and so we are in embarked
in the past couple of months on a very
massive initiative to improve the
protein names on these records and to
standardize the way we're formatting our
protein names of these records and so
you should look for improvements to
continue to come through the course of
this year and I can't spend too much
more time on this I think I'm over my
webinar ten minutes but if you'll bear
with me for a couple more minutes this
is a picture of a new web page display
called the identical protein report you
can get to this from any protein record
there's a link at the top of the page in
the same location as
faster graphics link shown here to
access this page this is a very useful
page it tells you how many genomes a
given protein record was annotated on in
this case I box 3 so this same protein
accession number has been annotated on
three different reps each genomes the
accessions are shown here and the
coordinates of the annotation are shown
here the organism information is shown
in the column to the right and so you
can see that these are three very
different bacterial organisms and the
lowest common denominator for these is
at the bacteria level in some cases this
may be an indicator that there was a
problem in identifying the correct
organism for a submission but in other
cases this is really reflecting very
interesting biology and last but not
least in the process of converting to
our new data model there was an awful
lot of suppression that happened we
suppress the intermediate level of
records the Y P and NP accession numbers
on all of our representative invariant
genomes I just want to make a note that
for the reference genomes they continue
to use the data model where there is an
independent accession defined for those
for the reference genomes for those
records that were suppressed we have
provided a custom message on those
records so if you go to this URL you
will see a very important message
provided that tells you that this
accession that has been suppressed has
indeed been replaced by and I get an on
redundant protein record then you can
navigate to that protein record to the
identical protein report or a
documentation about our me annotation
project and last there is a
comprehensive mapping file provided for
those who would like to have a
comprehensive report by FTP this file is
available in the refseq release catalog
directory this was put out in the
beginning of this month in july when we
process our next refseq release this
file will be moved into the release
catalog archive directory will where it
will continue to be available this file
provides mapping that
the old suppressed protein accession
number to the alive non-redundant
protein accession that is replacing it
it also mapped old locus tags - new
locus tags we had to annotate our
genomes with new locus tags because we
are now providing de novo genome
annotation for all of our records and
there are some new genes that are being
called so we cannot rely on the existing
locus tags that may have been submitted
it also reports information on gene ID
mapping for people who are interested in
that information commencing as gene
resource and I would just like to thank
people who have done all of the work on
these changes if you have questions you
can look at the online documentation
that my provided links to in these
slides you can also look at our FAQ or
you can contact us and either info at
NCBI or webinars at NCBI to follow up
with questions thank you so the question
is what is the source of the annotations
qualifiers attached to the non-redundant
protein entry and what is the procedure
if I have a question about that
annotation so are you talking about I'm
not sure exactly what you mean by
qualifiers you're talking about the
organism information the protein name or
something else oh the the product so
you're talking about the protein name so
initially the source was what came in
from GenBank NCBI has been working on
protein clustering and naming things
that are similar by homology for a
couple of years in the beginning of
March we created this new name
management database that really gives us
a lot of power to improve our protein
names and we have already improved about
1.2 million protein names and this is a
an area that we are extremely actively
working on so if you have specific name
examples then yes please send them if ik
names that are bad then yes please send
that information to us we're very very
interested in improving the quality of
the names on our non-redundant protein
records and you can use the info at NCBI
email to contact us for that ok that
looks like all of the questions if you
think of something else go ahead and
send those
the webinars at NCBI email address and
we'll get those included in the
documentation for this webinar thank you
very much we're gonna sign up now and
we'll see you at the next Vince VI
minute goodbye